i own a portfolio of companies that does
85 million a year and i have nothing to
sell you and i was recently invited to
taki moore's masterminded keynote for
his eight figure and up group and it was
a really fun discussion and presentation
that i was able to give i was very
humbled to have been invited and we
talked about two main things that those
business owners wanted to know so if
you're not at that level this may not be
for you but we talked about two things
the first was how to scale a high
performance sales team so among our
portfolio companies i think the biggest
team we have in those companies is a 26
person sales team so we know what it
looks like to recruit hire manage
incentivize and drive high performance
sales we've done that for both inbound
and outbound sales meaning cold calls
versus taking you know phone funnel type
type inbound leads through applications
so we've done both of those and the
other was more high level so the
conversation is kind of split into two
pieces one is focused very very sales
focused and the second is focused on
what i would consider high level
observations of entrepreneurship of
things that we've learned lessons
beliefs that have served us well um in
creating the portfolio company that we
have so uh if you don't know who i am
i'm alex mozy i own acquisition.com i
have nothing to sell you and i hope you
enjoyed the video uh so this is alex and
layla power team uh they run a portfolio
of companies uh probably many of you
guys know them from their gym launch
days and times uh team what i'd love to
chat with you about is scaling legion
with um with outbound uh and then uh
let's talk about uh scaling and exiting
dude can we talk about outbound because
a while ago like when we first met you
were like the king of the ads right yeah
and then you then you worked and the ads
kind of disappeared and i want to know
kind of what
i don't want too many people to know
that though
are we allowed to know that or you don't
no you no no no no
we're we're we're cool everybody here
under a friendly a that's my
understanding right friendy a yes 100
friendly if you're cool with that can
you type for nda into the chat
means everybody's officially signed
so um i think i think it would it would
serve everyone to do a little bit of
backstory in terms of why like why would
you even start something like this right
because you're like i'm already killing
it on facebook i'm killing on tick-tock
i've got youtube guides going etc
i will say that
i'll tell you why i started which will
probably lead into the second half of
this story which is what um i i told
taki was like i want you to talk about
this and i was like i really want to
talk about this and he was like okay
well how about we talk about my thing
first and then we start with your thing
yeah so
um
uh two years ago legal and i uh you know
we were we were you know we at that time
only had two businesses we had gym
launch and prestige labs one is the
supplement company one is a gym
licensing company and the company at
that time was doing about a million a
week
and we just finished our best month ever
and we're walking outside and she looks
at me and she's like i don't [ __ ] do
this anymore she's like let's shut it
down and i was like well
uh okay
uh maybe
um let's you know let's see if we can
get anything for this right so i just
immediately was like i just agreed i was
cool i was in tons of pain as an
entrepreneur just you know doing all the
things
and um
anyways i called up a friend of mine who
was in the space and he was an
investment banker he had sold similar
companies and i was like hey these are
our numbers like what do you think we
get for this
and he was like holy [ __ ] he's like
you get like 250 million if you just
finish the next 12 months at this rate
and i was like
250
million
with an m
he was like yeah you did 17 million
profit your second year like yes i can
yes we could do that so look at layla i
was like
well [ __ ]
you got 12 months in and she was like i
got 12 months for 250. i was like okay
let's do this right
and so that began what became a two and
a half year journey um that eventually
uh resolved in us selling the business
and so i want to walk through kind of
that process and the first year of that
was us realizing that we didn't actually
have a business we had a big guru brand
right um at the end of the day i was at
the events i was the one who made the
products i was the one who did the
coaching calls every week
probably something that some in a
similar spot that some of you guys are
in
and so um the the biggest kind of
weakness was that i was inextricably
linked with the brain so that was number
one number two and this is what i'm
going to focus on first and this i'll
hopefully tie both these stories
together is that we were we were channel
dependent all right and so we were
selling uh gym owners right so business
owners so we're not in like the online
fitness space we're hardcore brick and
mortar the i talked to a couple of
bankers a couple private equity firms
people that i knew through the network
asked them for people and i was like
what do you see as the weaknesses in our
business like how can we make this
better and the two big the three big
things they said were churn
uh in terms of how long customers stayed
they said
my name being the brand and the fact
that we were channel dependent on
instagram and facebook and that was it
and that was 100 of our of our sales
sales funnel
and so we kind of set out to fix that
and so
um
i'll just talk about outbound since that
was the channel that we chose to be our
next thing and it was because i could
never get youtube to work in my niche um
you know if you're a little more mass i
think it's
maybe i'm a [ __ ] it's very possible but
i couldn't get it to work um we have
seen tiktok working as a side note but
for today we'll talk about outbound
so
the outbound process takes significantly
longer than most people expect
that being said
it's part of the reason that private
equity and potential acquirers will
value it is because it is this sturdy
machine because if tomorrow facebook ads
shut me down it doesn't matter
because if i literally have a phone we
can make money like a phone
which is crazy like the concept is still
foreign to me and so
i want to tell you the sales numbers so
that you can have perspective in terms
of how long this took
so the first month we made one sale the
second month we made two sales the third
month we made four sales i like whether
the
and mind you
this is months so you're like 90 days in
at this point you're like [ __ ] we've
been putting effort towards this etc
right and so one of the key differences
to note with manual outbound whether
you're doing cold calls cold emails cold
text whatever it doesn't matter which
like the primary way of doing it we do a
combo and i'll get to that in a second
um
is that
every aspect of the funnel that we do
digitally is the same except it's purely
manual so you have
human variables
that contribute to every step in the
pipeline right
so
we did two we did four uh the next month
we did uh
i think it was six or eight uh and then
we jump to uh 12
and then we jump to uh 16 and then we
jump to and you'll notice that this
isn't uh quadratic so it's not
exponential what you will see there is
that it's more linear in nature it's
because we continue to add so our price
point is between right now it's 20 000
is the cheapest thing we sell which is a
great point bill so thank you for
bringing this up
if you want to do outbound your ticket
has to be at least 15 000.
like the the the uni economics don't
really work
i guess they do i just prefer to have
lots of margin but
in theory it should be 15 times a 15k or
more right and so for us our lcv is 40
thousand dollars at current right now
it's gone up but when we started this
the ltd was 40k because i started this
in corona for brick and mortar gyms
because we're brilliant right
so
if you continue this thing out um it
took
so we're now we passed
we're at month 14 from when we started
and now uh 14 months in
uh it does about 45 sales a month
which for us is roughly 60 of our sales
volume so we we we hit the halfway point
and now we're a little more than half
um in that in between yeah it's probably
better than me pretending to draw i'll
get to my drawing thing in a second or
you'll be able to do it better
so i i wanted to set this as a precedent
because i had two different times where
my leaders came to me and were like dude
should we continue to do this and i just
remember looking at them and i was like
this is why no one will remember your
name uh i'm kidding i didn't actually
say that um but but i was like guys as
long as we're seeing progress through
the funnel we have to continue because
the end goal is i either have to own
this thing for the rest of my life which
is okay
or
and i need to do it without it being
dependent on a single channel which i
should do as an owner regardless and
that'll feed into the second part of the
story
or or we'll never will never be able to
get out of this or or exit it either way
because you have to exit right every you
know we have to sell and we're either
selling it from our old self to our new
self we're selling it from our old
selves to a new acquirer but either way
we have to get out of it um the channel
dependency at a certain point if you're
below 10 million i don't think you need
to worry about this but once you're you
know once you're at 10 million i think
adding the second channel is important
in terms of the uh tactics around this
understanding the organizational chart
which creates the sale and the actual
process of the sale is kind of where we
should start so there are three
different roles in our sales system all
right the first
is we have we you know different there's
sdr bdr the whole point is that it's the
cult it's the first touch point it's the
outbound person sdrs and bdrs i think we
call them what do we call them
ddrs i don't remember whatever yeah
yeah
i think we call them bdrs so
and this is an important point for
everyone it's good that you leave this
this three the three lines because this
is cool because there's going to be more
detail in each of them
so we've got bdrs as level one level two
we've got sds which is sales development
specialist these guys qualify the leads
and provide the value
that the original person was promising
the third person is what we call bc so
business consultants and these are the
closers right
we technically have a fourth for we have
another team that does all of our
ascensions
um that sells the the 40k product but
this is uh and it looks like a christmas
tree if you were to look at the org
chart like this right you got the base
of bdrs who feed
half as many
uh sds who then feed half as many uh bcs
in
this model
if you replace a bdr mentally with what
an advertisement used to do that's
exactly how this functions the exception
to this process compared to your uh
inbound efforts are there's usually one
additional call
typically
so
what we do is that you we scrape lists
off of google we have vas in the
philippines enrich the data which just
means that they make sure that these are
real
real gym owners that have actual
facilities and these numbers work and
these emails are verified
um the actual like what software they
use i honestly have no idea because the
person who manages that team is too
sensitive for me but that's what they do
from there
our bdr team calls this list through
phone murder so phone burner is the tool
we use we really like it it's it's been
exceptional i highly recommend it
those bdrs are required to make a
hundred calls a day
the way that we structure this is that
they get four hours to work per day
all right and
we purposely set it up that way so that
we could have good sales people who want
to who want a moonlight so they've got
extra hours and they do call blocks
the other reason is because the sales
manager that i hired to build this
entire team
his experience was that people cannot be
productive for eight hours straight cold
calling he said if you give them eight
hours of pay he's like they'll do five
and a half hours of calls he's like so
you might as well do four hours of pay
and get three and a half
and so that was an efficiency thing they
are still expected to make 100 calls a
day
from those hundred calls they are
expected to have two appointments that
show
now we have been doing this a long time
now and each of these steps took like
each one of the things that i just
mentioned probably took two to four
weeks to figure out
where do we scrape the data
how do we how do we enrich it because
we're calling all these bad numbers
right now that we're getting people to
uh pick up
which by the way phone burner wraps it
with a local area code if you don't have
that feature there's no point in using
it like you need to wrap in a little
gear code or your picker braids can be
[ __ ] all right
so from there you'll get your 100 dials
you'll get 20 to pick up so it's 100 to
20 from the 20 we will have two who
schedule and show i only know the two
because that's the only thing we
compensate them on all right and so the
expectation is that they get two in the
beginning it'll be one yes
all right uh
100 to 20 to two
what's the
uh
dumb question what's the 20 what's the
two
20 is 20 pickups
so 100 dials 20 pickup hello of the 20
to pick up we get one to two uh to to
show
uh and that's to show
for the sds yep exactly now this is a
good thing for you guys too is that
every once in a while you'll get you'll
get a savage and you'll know because
they'll set five of that because if you
guys picked up the phone and do it you
could set five points if someone picked
up you could probably set up right but
somebody who's newer the nice thing with
the bdrs is it takes two days to ramp
them up it's not a hard position to
teach yes here's the list here's the
phone say these words the phone calls
are like five to ten minutes like
they're not hard to train and if you
have a big repertoire of existing calls
which you will
uh it's easy to just have them listen to
those so uh
can we can i be a gym for a second yeah
oh i've never done the calls i have no
idea
do you have a rough idea what they say
what it's about
so our our whole pitch is basically like
hey we've been calling some gyms in the
area um they've been struggling with xyz
you know biggest concern one two and
three
and so what we're doing is like if gyms
don't exist our company doesn't exist
and so we'd like to just give you some
of the stuff that's working well for
them is that okay this is from our
private client thing which normally we
charge for but we just want to help
jim's out
cool okay so what i'll do is i'll set
you up with an appointment uh with sean
tomorrow and he'll run through each of
these systems for your gym
uh so that you can insert dream outcome
that you want which is get more leads
make more sales charge more for it yeah
awesome okay that's super helpful yeah
and the bdrs will typically uh if
they're good they'll look up the gym
before they make the call um and so they
can be like hey saw that you posted that
thing
yeah i'm calling you know from gymlodge
don't worry like just want to help you
guys out we're talking a lot of gyms in
the area like tonality matters right
like that's the stuff that the manager
will teach them um but it's like this is
a good well play for us it's like we
just wanna help you out we're gonna give
you some stuff
no no strings attached they say cool and
then they show up for the sds right
now getting getting them to show for the
sds it's like you got to get them to
show sooner we need to make sure that
the thing that you were giving them they
truly perceive is valuable and this is
probably one of the biggest things that
i can that i can if i can
this one took us longer to figure out is
and i don't think like lead magnets and
stuff like that
is valuable
like it's got to be like it has to be
something that people really want in
your space so even if it's something
that's unscalable
do it unscalable and then figure out a
system to scale it once you get the um
once you get the flow going right
because in the beginning you're gonna
have one or two callers it's not going
to be a ton of volume i promise you um
and then you'll you'll be able to figure
out what's the thing that gets them to
show up that they really want right can
you get on i mean back in
yes sorry dude can you give us an
example of what a valuable not lead
magnet useful thing might be
i think we walk them through uh
how to set up their sales room and the
scripting that they use that that we get
you know double the amount of people who
sign up for whatever so it's a really
valuable thing right yeah and then it's
like yeah you'll walk him through he can
show you around blah blah blah blah and
then
amazing yeah the cool thing
and they can sell the benefits like if
you had twice as many people signed up
and nothing else changed in your life
would that be cool cool all right he's
going to show you how we do it because
this is what the top one percent of gyms
are doing we should help you out
okay loving the script we just want to
help you out high valuable thing old
school telemarketing rob nixon you love
this sharan says
so once we uh once we get them to the
sds the sds's full requirement um is
that they provide value crazy as [ __ ] i
know is that you actually deliver the
thing that they think is really cool now
here's the key point is that we want to
show expertise so the sds for us almost
exclusively is ex-clients now we may be
in a situation where
you know our clients are able to do that
like you have to show some domain
expertise especially around this thing
and the idea is if we can show a couple
of like really in-depth nuggets that are
like [ __ ] i didn't think about that
while they're going through the process
they're like [ __ ] these guys know what
they're talking about and so what
happens is we we terminate the
uh
the the value delivery and we purposely
leave about 15 minutes at the end
you know of dead time that we would
transition to getting them set up on
another call how long is this call
i think it's 45. so it's 30 to do the
thing 15 to set the next uh deal
perfect
the the sds is like hey you know i
couldn't can i can i switch hats for a
second i know i'm just here to help you
out but and we purposely make that to
change the
the frame right we're trying to make a
little little frame shift which is like
i couldn't help it here when you were
saying some of these things
i couldn't like this this stood out to
me this stood out to me this have you
thought about these things
because honestly i just showed you this
little thing but that's like one percent
of actually the amount of juice you
could squeeze at your gym because like
if we just did the thing that we just
talked about you double your business
but like what about orders of magnitude
what if we can get to like 5x the
business because right now you're
running 10 margins and if we can get you
to 35 we just three and a half extra
take home income only by changing the
way you price would that be valuable
okay cool so do you know what we do
because at this point we haven't talked
about us at all so think about it first
call all about them value second call
providing value second half of that call
couldn't help but xyz i don't normally
do this blah blah
do you know what we actually do
and they're like no i was like oh shoot
i i feel so stupid yeah so we literally
help people just like you fix the thing
that you just said you want with the
thing you know
by overcoming your biggest insecurity
and fear and they're like oh my god
that's awesome it's like you know we
actually do this 100 gyms a month like
we can we can walk like this is our
bread and butter i didn't know you
actually needed this i just wanted to
provide this for you to help you out
oh wow well okay
let me see here hold on let me check
with one of the one of our guys you got
15 minutes okay cool we're good um
you're a business owner why don't we see
if we can um
uh set this up for you right now right
let's be efficient with your time
hold on one second
so then we call
the closer yeah we call the closer live
and then they have a dialogue that's
scripted but it's speaker phones yeah
the person who's on zoom right now
doesn't know that this conversation is
scripted but they can hear both sides
and this guy's like dude i'm super busy
i got so many gyms i got to talk to um i
got a hard stop of 15. i can maybe hop
on um okay no this guy's really awesome
he's a qualified gym no he's legit he's
big enough for us okay okay you got to
make sure he's the right size and that
he's got the that he understands what we
do oh yeah no no it's all good right
okay cool then i got i can hop on for 15
minutes
guy hops into
the zoom makes the introduction and the
goal here is not to sell them
the goal is just to connect them and
build rapport that's all it is because
we could not get the s and this took us
like two months to figure out we could
not get the sds to show for the close
calls like those the qualified
appointments we couldn't get them they
would set it but they wouldn't show up
and so
we tried doing three-way text we tried
like we tried a bunch of things but if
you do the face-to-face where they hop
on the call
then they're like
yeah perfect well i gotta go in five but
i've got you down for tomorrow at four
we're good to go and rock and roll right
and just to be clear like this is no
longer us giving you thing i'm gonna
explain how our services work our
pricing and see if it's a good fit right
and so they clearly set the expectation
that this is a sales call and that i
will be trying to close you and we're
very clear about that yeah and it's cool
because we just had two calls we
provided value at this point we
transitioned they show up the next day
and it's and it's just like your inbound
closing
dude
so here's the advantage to this there's
there's so much more so here's the
advantage to this model so
four callers sorry sorry uh uh if you're
looking at appointments right yep
for us we close uh
10
of
of scheduled
sds so if there's two of these right two
of those we closed ten percent of those
of showed uh set calls we closed ten
percent
so we closed point two
uh in that example right yeah exactly
and so
for us
the cost uh to acquire a customer from
an advertising i'll use cold calling as
the advertising here
is they get they get uh they get 50
bucks for every show
so it's 500
right so it's 500 bucks in
in bdrs per close
which for a 40 000 ltv is pretty cool
and so that works out pretty well for us
and so the beautiful part about this
model is that it takes so the downsides
are the upsides with this it takes a
long time to build and it's
and it also is impossible to break
yes and i can tell you i sleep so much
better as a business owner knowing that
no matter what happens tomorrow we're
going to close deals
so this is the part that i think
everyone needs to uh if you want to
scroll up on this is the
this is the the more genius
you'll need a fresh page so
i got you
so this is a key point that is sexy as
[ __ ]
all right um
who here would love to have a sales team
system
a farm for building sales people so
we so my ceo uh was an ex-pro baseball
player so we use the pro baseball player
analogy a lot
so
right there in front of you you've and
we even use that we even use the terms
right so we've got double a we've got
triple a and we've got the bigs right
and so double a is the bdrs
aaa is the sds's and then the biggs is
like the big leagues right
and so the key point here and this is
like for those of you guys who are
building 30 million like 50 like this is
where this gets interesting for everyone
right is that
the the human resource
training system itself becomes an asset
to the business because we know that
when someone works their way up from
being a bdr all the way to a bc they
know how to [ __ ] close
because these people were never spoiled
with inbound leads they got hung up on
and cussed at and so you guys want to
know an interesting stat
our inbound closing percentage and we
were considered pretty good at sales
before this
went from 20 20 to 25
to 60
yeah wow because they were they cut
their teeth
at the bottom yeah they're like this
person
knows who we are asked for help and
wants more information
they're like for real
okay
and so
here's here's why this is important to
titles so
bdr there's four levels of bdrs
you've got junior bdrs you got associate
bdrs you've got bdr and you've got
senior bdr
and that same four step system applies
to all of the levels give me the junior
junior yep associate yeah the name
and then uh was the top thing i just
said um senior yeah
so
think about your highest churn positions
right the reason that the positions are
high churn is because they cannot see
progress people lose hope when they run
out of future right i think i'd damn or
tell us that i really like that so they
run out of future so what we need to do
is create
yeah we need to create future for them
and so
it's my belief that a salesperson has
like six to eight weeks of steam in them
before they start getting disheartened
and so what we did is that we created
milestones which are those qualifiers on
the right
where
if you hit a an objective qualifier you
move up
and so if as a junior it would probably
be 50 showed appointments which will
take you about eight weeks
after that would be a hundred and then
it and each one of these increases and
you'll know for your business it might
be a little different but the point is
that you want to pace it so it's about
eight weeks of production between each
one
now
each one of these gives them a bump in
title and a bump in pay the pay bump is
virtually inconsequential we go from 50
bucks to like 55 bucks like it's not a
huge deal but to them they feel like
they're making progress in both status
and they have an objective measure of
their of how well they're doing now once
they move their way through this and
then imagine this you're a new employee
you're getting trained up and then boom
eight weeks in you get a promotion
you're like oh
nice i'm doing well this is good and
then they gain some steam and then boom
dude eight weeks later they're like hey
i'm a full bdr you know i mean like this
is great i got another raise
once they get to the top of this ladder
this is the key key nuance
you don't get promoted you get the
ability to be promoted yeah this is when
you get to here senior yeah yeah once
you're a senior bdr
you now have the ability to be promoted
the benefit of this is it also
eliminates all the hr conversations for
i want more money we're like here's the
path that's it this is the career path
it also helps people become career
sales people for you so if you have
issues of churn
for your sales team this gives them a
like this is what my career path is
here's an important point
you probably heard what i said about the
bdrs they do not get paid very much they
don't they're they're on target earnings
if they hit all the commissions is 40
grand yeah right now how do you attract
someone
who can do this job well for forty
thousand dollars
you don't
you attract them because they know that
the guys who win the lottery make 200
grand a year
[Music]
and they know because they have a clear
career path in front of them that if
they hit their metrics they could get
there nine to twelve months yeah so i'm
like what job in the world can you go
from zero to two hundred thousand a year
in nine to twelve months with no degree
here you can because we're pure
meritocracy and the numbers don't lie
and so
at the sds level it's the same exact
thing jumer sds uh uh
associate
the just the word and then senior right
so we have each of these levels and
there's tiny bumps in comp for each of
those
and they really should just be almost uh
symbolic more than they are significant
because like the title is more important
than the cash but the cash just goes
okay and because you yeah yeah
exactly you honestly you could probably
get away with this without even changing
anything but i like i like to give a
little something and then they feel like
there's there's some stuff ricky's got a
question if someone's level if someone's
results stopped or their levels dropped
yes
okay
so you can go for something
associate or whatever you have to you
have to continue to earn your position
if you if you drop below qualifiers you
drop down you go back to triple a just
like baseball you go back down
yeah they get relegated exactly it's
exactly that
and the nice thing is because of this
everyone knows where they stand so it
cuts down some of the useless
communication of like pay and what am i
doing and how well i'm it's like dude
it's right here everybody can see it
right and it's built like this christmas
tree because they see the top closure
and they see their checks they're like
[ __ ] that could be me right they know
they get they're counting the weeks
until they can get there now when we
start scaling because we add more bdrs
it trickles up the tree and we're going
to need another
uh closer and so we look at the guys who
are who are qualified to be promoted and
we pick the one that we think is the
best fit and they get bumped they get
bumped up to the bigs and then they and
then it's it's tried out like they've
got two weeks to show us if they can
close if they can't close in two weeks
they drop back down
they get 10 deals
everyone's curious you get 10 deals to
try
you don't close one out of 10 you're out
realistically should close more but
their first 10 they got to close them
yep and the reasoning behind that is
i've i've run and trained and scaled a
lot of sales teams i have yet to find a
killer who doesn't close in the first
two weeks yeah not once yeah tons of
guys who start hot and then fizzle but
no one who starts cold and then gets
good
what are your
uh
qualifiers for
sds and well bc's clearly say you know
deals done
sds is just bc it's it's it's qualified
shows yeah
so they have to they have to qualify
them and they have to get them to show
that's that's really it yep
because for example in that call if they
can't get the person to be like yeah
tell me more about that and they're like
nah i'm [ __ ] good then they missed it
right and so
that's why the domain expertise for the
sds like lots of really cool little like
if you have two or three really good
nuggets that you always know are awesome
weave it into that conversation and
they're like [ __ ] and you're like dude
this is like this much this is like my
fingernail of how big this is like you
should like the fact that you didn't
know this
it both worries me and excites me
for the opportunity that i think you
have in front of you
and honestly i'm not qualified to talk
about it but this guy who's got a dick
bigger than shaq and you know cured
cancer by age six and helped five
thousand people just like you be better
than who you are like he can help you
let me see if he's available he really
never is he's always booked let me check
and then and then he does the thing yeah
i love it so
we've talked about
uh we've talked about this we've talked
about that
yeah uh
bc call um my hunch is it's closer
framework
yeah can you just give us like
those videos yeah so
yeah yeah so um we use i i like to teach
a really simple simple acronym both most
you guys on here already know how to
close so you know i won't bore you with
it but yeah you could use your own or if
you don't have one you could model from
this there might be something good still
yeah so we make sure that every script
uh follows close receive points um it's
always a question-based framework so we
like questions because people can just
like say get off into jupiter and you
just ask them another question that
brings them back um
each of these is kind of a milestone
along the path so c is clarify why
they're there right it sounds obvious
right but it's like hey so i know you
you know you wanted some help with the
sales thing i know that provided some
value to you i know you talked to john
and he showed you a couple more things
so like why'd you decide to take all
this time like what's what's important
to you about this like why are you not
getting what you want like why did you
even take the time to show up at the
spot right and then they're like well
and they're like well i wanted more
information it's like you just get
information all day you're trying to
solve something with the information you
know because that would be that would be
a smoke screen right
like right so as soon as we get it then
we nail them down and we label it which
is l so it's like okay so i hear what
you're saying this is the reason you
show up for the call so i just want to
be clear that if we achieve this outcome
for you you would be happy right you
would be like you guys rock i love you
awesome you can imagine that okay great
okay so you've wanted this
so we go to o which is overview your
past pain right we call this the pain
cycle so we're like okay so you've
wanted this for however long
and what have you done so far to try
because you seem like a pretty you know
well-to-do person you seem like you've
got some work ethic so i'm sure this
isn't the first thing you know first
phone call you've hopped on so like what
have you done so far they go through it
we said got it how'd that work for you
what was good what was bad whenever they
say something good we say totally and we
agree with it if they say something was
bad we're like oh that's terrible and we
disagree unless there's a limiting
belief that we need to pop before we get
into the close yep
then we go right back to the beginning
we say what else have you done and we
keep going until there's nothing left or
like god i can totally understand why
you'd be frustrated at this point
because it seems like you've done a lot
so i feel like you've got a lot of
pieces because the goal here is to make
them feel like they're six inches away
and they need one link to be successful
totally right yeah dude you've got all
these right things in place you're so
close i mean gosh i feel like
like you've got you're this close to
hitting your goal so
you've done all this stuff this is what
you want this is why you're here do you
want to hear like i think you'd be a
good fit for the program how it works
and they say yes we get permission and
then we go into s which is sell the
vacation so the reason we call cell
vacation is that a lot of most people
here already know this but a lot of
sales people will sell your program
right which is the plane flight they're
selling tsa airbags take your shoes off
weigh your mass get vaccinated don't get
vaccinated you know sit next to the
person who fires you on the plane you're
gonna get terrible peanuts all of that
and they're like yeah but then you're
gonna get them out and people were like
it's like you gotta sell them out you
gotta be talking about the trees and the
wind and what it's gonna be like to feel
and experience that the status increase
they will have amongst their peers as a
result of this this decision and they're
like got it okay and when we do the
solid vacation we typically will limit
it to three main points and i think it's
just because human attention span isn't
that good so you probably do tons of
stuff
we do tons of stuff we only talk about
three things right talk about get more
customers how to make it worth more how
to get them buy more times that's it
right and these are the things that
we're gonna help them do and we give a
relevant analogy to those things so
uh you know we just you want to have a
quick anecdote that's 30 seconds or less
so if i was selling a a coaching program
for whatever
accountability might be one of my three
things and i'd be like okay well and
this would tie to whatever the thing
they struggled with in the past it's
like you know i signed for stuff but i
didn't really get it going i was
struggling to like do it whatever like
totally understand it's reasonable what
do they do to hold you down when they're
like well nothing it's like well then
that's not your fault they didn't hold
you accountable of course you weren't
successful that's not that's not you
right so let me ask you a question when
you were a kid
did you uh did you love brushing your
teeth tonight and they were like no
you're like did you go like oh mom
you know you dragged me out of bed you
brushed your teeth right and they kept
doing that over and over every night you
got to keep doing that doing that do you
brush your teeth now as an adult they're
like well i mean yeah not a [ __ ]
disgusting [ __ ] you're like yeah so
what that was an example of is you could
have external accountability that turned
into internal motivation and that's
exactly what we're going to do with you
here in this program does that make
sense great we don't talk about [ __ ]
zoom calls we don't talk about support
we don't talk about our like don't talk
about that because that doesn't matter
they just want to know that something
external is going to get them to do
something internal forever so we give
them an anecdote about that and so this
is important because this is the only
thing the sales guys have to memorize
besides obstacle overcomes the rest of
this is is questions that they can
always refer back to all right so for
ramping up sales guys faster
question-based framework not scripting
this is just in my experience it's
easier to teach people
i i haven't found in my experience the
super scripted stuff is best for like 20
minutes super high transactional sales
like 200 sales and less but that's
probably not what anyone here is selling
so
for everyone else question based
framework kind of a diagnostic approach
we follow this e is explaining with our
concerns which is like got it this is
the thing so that makes sense would you
be would you be opposed to moving
forward today because it sounds like a
good fit um then they're like well i
wouldn't be a pleasure before today
you're like great and if for some reason
they say yes what we do is we do the
exact same thing every time which was we
make some sort of concession which is a
bonus and then we say fair enough
because all we're doing is concession
reciprocity fair enough and people don't
like to feel like they're not being fair
it's a very human thing is reciprocity's
super deep in us and so if someone's
like i don't know if i can do this like
how about i throw this in yeah three
times like okay it's got to be fair
enough by now
right
and so we explain with our concerns
which you guys probably already know
you've got spouse slash decision maker
you've got price and you've got uh delay
which is i need to think about it i need
more information i got to sleep on it
whatever and so for each of those rather
than give you the things that we would
drill our sales teams on uh a decision
maker close is going to
adhere to the principles behind getting
someone to understand past agreements
which is
does your spouse or business partner
know that you are struggling with this
yes
do they want you to continue to struggle
with this
no
why would they be against you fixing
something they already know you're
struggling with and they don't want you
to keep struggling with so we're relying
on the past agreements to go into the
present and then we they're like i guess
you're right and then we usually will
tag in a hey sometimes you better ask
for forgiveness information fair enough
right and then we will close them that
would be for a decision maker for a
um
for a uh if it's by the way if it's b to
c you can usually get away with uh what
if they say no
and honestly you'd be [ __ ] i'd still
blows my mind you were like i'd probably
do it anyways you're like then let's do
it so you know so it's rock and roll
like but if it's if it's b to b you
probably go past your grants and then uh
and then usually if you have some sort
of guarantee or some sort out clause of
like three days or five days if you you
know get back and your business partners
and usually we'll make a joke here hey
you get back your best partner says hey
man i want you to be poor i want your
kids not to have anything i want you
live in the worst neighborhoods i don't
want you to have generational wealth i
want you to just pass on a spirit of
poverty to all of the things that spring
you know fruit from your loins if that's
if that's what your business partner
says like totally understand and we'll
just tear this up but if he's like nah
man that sounds good then we'll rock and
roll right and if he does say that first
thing you get have him give me a call
and i'll talk to him fair enough great
there we go so decision maker we've got
price which is always anchored around
value this is usually more that you
actually have to close on the sales guys
not the prospects i'm gonna be really
real with you we don't drill price stuff
that much we drill the sales team on
their conviction
so has anyone here ever had like a
client event and had all these people
there and get testimonials and like your
sales team was there
yesterday
right well i'll bet you for the next
couple weeks
your closing percentage is going to be
[ __ ] sky high i could tell you that
when i had my brick and mortar gyms i
would do weigh-out days which is like
when challenges and stuff would end and
people would be losing weight and crying
and all that stuff i would stack as many
sales appointments as i possibly could
while the layouts were happening because
my sales team was just watching people
just hit their goal and hit their goal
and they're like dude just sign up like
they would even go through a pitch
they're like i mean what do you have
that like just sign up like it yeah and
they reeked of conviction and the
funniest thing in the world for
everybody here is like understanding the
theory behind sales is that you have a
person who has conviction
and then you have another person who has
no conviction and everyone knows that
sales is a transference of conviction
right it's a transference of belief and
the bridge of that is trust
right and so the real intention is that
we must make sure that a salesperson
actually believes and you'd be amazed at
how many times they don't really believe
in the product yeah and one of the
things that is important to understand
is it's not a binary it's not do my
sales guys believe in my product yes it
is how much do they believe in my
product
hey alex yeah this is epic
okay
you know what i love
uh i said i'd like you to talk about
this and you said no i want to talk
about that and i said well let's do both
you've done a really good job of doing
what i wanted to talk about so um i like
talking about sales no i get it uh in a
minute what i'd love to do let's just do
the third objection to kind of close the
triangle here and then let's do a quick
q a and then let's talk about scaling
and selling is that cool yeah
um so last ones uh i need to think about
it and so for most people they don't
know how to make a good decision
they're afraid of making a mistake and
so we like to be as direct as possible
which is like let's toss best best case
worst case this is what happens this is
what happens because tell me what your
deepest darkest fear is right is that i
take your money and xyz that you think
is gonna happen is it gonna happen but
not only that let's be real your husband
thinks you're a failure because you
spent money again right your friends are
like oh here she is again you know or
here he is making another [ __ ]
business program thinking he's gonna
make money right that's what the real
pain is right it's not the money i mean
sure but the thing is that the money's
going to come back right because you're
not going to go homeless and even if you
do go homeless i've got guys who've
living outside my building for 25 years
not starving still good so you really
have nothing to worry about right but
the real thing here is that we need to
make this decision so do you know how to
make the we have a decision making
framework here can we can i share it
with you sure so first question yes or
no do you think that we can help you
solve this problem yes
cool do you like me or do you want to
work with us as a company yes
cool
do you have access
to the amount of money that is required
to start yes or no if it's yes yes yes
let's rock and roll because the end of
the day you don't need more time you
need more information to make a decision
and i'm your source of information and i
can do this all day feels like you've
done this once or twice
this is i'm making the summers ago
100
uh okay sheila just wants to know the r
in closer is
just reinforce their decision that's a
great one so close was actually my my
acronym for like two years when i was
teaching and then after really looking
at it as the beginning of the customer
journey yeah uh we transitioned to
having instead of a handoff it is a
handshake between sales and customer
success
and so the point here is that the moment
they close the moment the card goes
through they're gonna have immediate
remorse and so our goal is to totally
reinforce the decision personalize video
from the next person be like hey just
got off the phones john i hear it and
this is an important point from an
operational standpoint it's like hey i
heard you're trying to retire your wife
i think that's amazing i heard that you
were trying to get to ten thousand
dollars a month i think you're gonna
blow that away you're gonna do such a
good job so just to give you a heads up
tomorrow it's me tammy i forgot to
introduce myself and we're gonna be
walking through xyz so that we can help
you get your your wife retired as fast
as possible cool really excited to see
you i sent you an email with all the
details too see you tomorrow right and
so now they're like okay this is a legit
company i just got you know i just got
off the phone you know the phone thing
and an hour later i get this thing i'm
like okay this is cool i feel good about
this decision and that's what we want
them to think i feel good about this
decision and we're like great and then
it decreases the the the cold feet and
walkouts and backups and all that [ __ ]
good job tammy i'd love to know one
thing you learned one thing you loved
any follow-up questions let's do it
right now and then we're going to switch
gears so one thing you want to kind of
nugget you stole
and any questions you've got lots of
exploding head emojis uh what's the comp
at each level
let's scroll up here for a second i
wouldn't i wouldn't give you hard and
fast what i'll give you is ote which is
on target earnings cool uh and that's
what that's also what we present to the
sales guys so this is the number of
opportunities if you're getting if
you're doing 100 the nice thing is that
here's the cool thing with outbound is
that it's reliable
ads you've got some days you've got more
somebody's got less maybe this campaign
maybe it's not outbound
it starts with a constant you make 100
calls yeah and everything after that is
is just formula right 100 calls means
means we should get two people to show
two people show we should get uh five of
those iterations to get one deal
and so forth and so if you're getting
this many appointments per week this is
relatively the amount that you should be
closing by percentage right if you close
less than this so if somebody's closing
let's say 25 or less they get up they
get bumped down
right
and so for us the the guys who are the
bigs they make the on the on the like if
they're doing great they make like 225
yeah the target earnings range for each
that's probably yeah 150 to say 120 to
220. is the range there for
for aaa or at the sds they make 60-ish
and that's a much tighter range probably
like 55 to 70 you know i mean like but
probably i don't think anyone said this
it's like 55 to 65 it's a 10k range
and then uh and then the uh
the bdrs are like around 40 grand
helpful
so you can see how they're shooting for
that yeah what they are yeah see it and
what they're like how long does it take
the answer is right in front of them on
the right that's how all it takes yeah
what i love about this is you're
thinking in
uh quick achievable win levels and
um
maria just said
love eight weeks probably the same for
our clients
something to think about
yeah uh jackson says where are you
finding these people uh the homeless
guys out the back that he talked about
before
yeah
candidly uh one of the big bombings in
the business was finding that and i
found out it took me
i made a whole youtube video about this
but uh basically my team was screening
way too hard
um
for bdrs and my sales manager didn't
know
and so we're like no no just let them
all in and
we'll see how they do because
the cost because it takes two days to
ramp them up and we don't really have
any cost per lead yeah i mean besides
the data scraping which is not that hard
and so we just let them prove themselves
because it doesn't really cost us
anything to have them work leads yeah
love it uh yuri's asking did you
consider cold outbound email instead of
called calls yeah i'm pretty sure phone
burner has a follow-up email uh and text
thing that goes with it but i'll be
honest with you guys like the phones are
the thing that that drive it 75 of it
comes from the phones yeah i love it
okay
so alex
when i said hey could you do a thing
about a thing and you said yes uh you
said i'd rather talk about what i
thought i would share with you guys if
that's okay with you is a couple of the
kind of key lessons i've learned in this
process
so i started this process because i was
in a tremendous amount of pain right and
i and i i ran out of future i couldn't
see uh a world where i'd want to
continue to do this for the long haul
right and i think i heard this from
sharon and i love it is that operators
get burned out business owners get rich
and i was still ceo
and that was the thing is that as much
as i felt like i wasn't doing anything
now two years ago i was 100 doing things
but this year
as we transitioned out i went from just
making decisions to not really make just
to just reviewing decisions which is
kind of what we're doing now
and so the reason that we got the offers
that we did in my opinion
um is because
we fixed the house
and when you fix the house that you're
trying to sell does anyone ever try to
sell a house and like you fix all the
things that they say are wrong with it
and then you look at the astral like why
are we leaving this place this place is
awesome have you ever done that yeah
well
the the biggest lesson that i feel like
i've taken from this and i have i have
two pages of lessons that i took i
documented through this process
um is that you only have one outcome you
have to sell the business but it doesn't
mean you have to have another acquirer
you can sell the business from yourself
to yourself yeah your own self to your
new self
and
i also got a greater understanding of
how the debt system works so if
someone's going to buy your business for
a big amount of money they're not
actually going to pay for your business
right they're going to put 30 down like
you do for a house and then they're
going to get a bank to finance the rest
right
you
have a house that you own 100 in cash
you can go to the bank and get the 70
mortgage on your house and just take the
money
in the u.s at least tax-free
jackson's nodding he would know the
aussie so he's nodding he's like yes
affirmative
and so the point is is that in my mind
two and a half years ago the only
possible outcome that i could do to get
out of pain was to sell and the thing
that i had to sell
was unsellable
and so
the thing that we build has to be
sellable
that's just my conclusion it has to be
sellable
or you'll eventually burn out
and so
if you make it sellable then it actually
sits as an asset on your personal net
worth balance sheet and it continues to
provide cash flow
um
i had so many stories that i would you
know that like the story of the sale for
me was like i need a big sale to to be
legit some of you guys may laugh at that
you're like you're doing 85 million here
but in my head i was like well and then
i had a friend who's like dude you've
already sold six companies i was like
yeah but they weren't like as big as
this he's like you really think that
matters i was like huh
and then it was like what about the what
about the story of of the money right
about the increase in net worth well
here's here's an interesting one for you
say you have 100 million dollar sale
right
everyone talks about it it's so amazing
well most of the times it's not 100
million dollars right what it is is
they'll probably give you you know
60 million up front and then you'll have
a
10 million dollar seller note that you
finance for five years
and then you'll have uh you'll have a
earn out right for another 20 million
uh that if you hit x y and z over the
next year or two right or earn outs can
be as long as they want right
um and uh you're going to roll another
10
in equity right and so all of a sudden
this 100 becomes sixty but wait there's
more
so now we've got sixty million well you
probably have some bonuses that you
wanna give to your staff you're gonna
have a broker that you'll probably have
to pay three or four percent to so let's
let's do it so four percent of 60 now
we're down to 57 right uh and i'll just
wrap in some of the bonuses on top of
that uh
depending on how your your equity
structure if you're 100 whatever then
you have your capital gains tax you have
an escrow fee
so capital gains for us in the states at
least is 20. so now we have 20 off of
the you know let's say 55 after the
escrow
that would be actually the size that big
it'd probably be more like 50 after
escrow uh 20 that would be 40 million
so now your 100 million dollar sale
is 40 million bucks
it's not as cool
right
at least for me like hearing how how it
would break down and so i've tried to be
as transparent as possible because like
there's the there's the story of the
sale that we tell ourselves
and there's the reality of the sale
because here's the second part of it i
talked about the money side but what
about the attention headspace energy
side because that was another story i
was like well if i sell then i'll be
able to go do stuff that i really you
know i'll get all this attention back
and all the stuff right
well
one the amount of stuff they want you to
do is gonna be directly proportional how
much stuff you're doing now so if you
want to sell the business you got to do
it in a way that you're not doing
anything and if you're not doing
anything then why sell the [ __ ]
business yeah and so for me i told
myself the story but the reality was
they wanted me to show up for
quarterlies and be available for the
occasional uh like strategic like hey
can we touch base about something
which is exactly what i currently do
yeah so
then it's no longer so it's not a
question of money because if you're
selling for that amount of money you've
probably been making money for a while
right so it's not going to materially
change your net worth unless you're in
software in which case it's a different
you know game but for most of us here
who sell service businesses of some kind
you're probably pretty high margin
pretty high cash flow and you probably
have a decent amount of money after you
get this kind of downstream impact of
what's actually going to be added to
your net worth then the question is what
am i going to take with the 40 million
and buy that's going to create me
because if you're selling for 100 you're
probably doing 15 million in in profit
right so what am i going to go buy with
40 million that i can get 15 million
dollars of profit every year from that i
don't have to do anything for right and
so i had the story of what the sale was
going to mean to me in terms of my
reputation which was completely living
in other people's eyes which was useless
and irrelevant and not true i had the
story of
money which is this is going to be a big
change in my life but when i looked at
all the numbers i was like this will
change nothing about my life in no way
like
nothing because unless you get into
another stratosphere of wealth yep like
it nothing's gonna change right so then
it goes into the energy and headspace i
was like okay well [ __ ] i'm doing the
same thing before as i am now and so
thing by thing there's the story of what
we think it is versus the reality of
what it is and so um
the the biggest thing that i feel like
uh
has been my biggest takeaway from this
is that when i've looked at and i have a
big thing on private equity lessons that
are really cool too but
it's probably running out of time um
i learned from the guy who lives above
me so the guy literally lives right here
he does 3.8 billion a year in in revenue
he owns his company 100 outright
and he does 26 net margins
privately held
that means he took home 935 million
dollars in income last year
the secret day of success he said i've
been doing the same thing for 40 years
40 years
and so
what i feel like i i continue to witness
is that the wealthiest people in the
world and i'm i'm stealing this from
charon because they buy and they build
and then they refinance so you don't
need to sell and the only reason that
you would sell is because you think the
party's over you think that this thing
is no longer going to be a thing anymore
long term yeah but if i make a bet that
gyms are going to be here in 10 years
which i do think gyms are going to be
here in 10 years right or your business
whatever the spaces is going to be there
in 10 years well then what's the reason
for selling
so and i got this from my closest friend
because he was like what problem are you
solving and i was like well when i
started this process i was in a ton of
pain he was like okay are you paying now
and i was like well not really he's like
well what do you think is gonna happen
post sale
he's like it's he's like [ __ ] the sale
he's like match the conditions
he's like what does your life look like
after the sale tactically yeah is there
a way that we can make your
your life look this way before the sale
and keep the damn thing yeah
and so then we started looking at it
from can we match the conditions and so
if you can do that
then you we build the thing instead of a
really high-paying ceo job we now have
an asset that is sellable and can can
carry debt on our balance sheet income
tax-free that we can then use to go
invest in the other stuff that we want
and as the company grows it pays off the
debt and you have the thing that you're
getting the debt who's continuing to
grow as well if that's what you want
all right dude
i got i got two thoughts in my head i
just want to throw them to you and you
can do something with them or not yeah
two things i see happen a lot in
boardroom is people hit their you know
their number it's not 100 million often
but it's the you know like it's like the
dream they've now hit it and they're
like well [ __ ] what the hell do i do now
um so that's a really common thing and
then the other thing
uh talking about exit not exit is really
interesting but one of the things you've
done to um
to get
exit a ball is to take the name off the
door
yeah totally so the name off the door i
just want to prepare everyone is like
it's like a three year process so it
takes a lot more time than you think it
will
this is i would just share the things
that work for us all right so
uh layla's just said we have no youtube
strategy honestly alex just likes making
videos in as a great teacher yes
thank you layla for i'm packing the
strategy yep that is the strategy um
so first thing is we edified customers
uh into specialists and the key nuance
here is that we don't make generalists
because generalist means they can
replace you and you actually either have
the problem of having another face
that's not yours or you have the risk of
that face walking but either way it's
either a face that doesn't make it
sellable which is the same weakness or
you have a face that becomes a threat to
the business right either way it's not
good and so we make siloed experts which
we call subject matter experts that
specialize in a specific thing so you
might have somebody who's really good at
sales somebody who's really good at lead
nurture somebody's really good at ad
buying somebody's really good at pages
somebody whatever the thing is so that
you can have people tag those clients
and they become kind of the the customer
support but like with special
specialization beyond that you take some
of the better customers you have who
want to exit their business and just
love your brand and you say hey would it
be cool if all you did was talk about
this all day and they're like dude this
is all i want to talk about anyone like
i don't like dancing anymore i want to
talk about dance right
um
and what if we just helped you just help
our clients better and then they become
the head of product right because if you
think about the things that we're
probably doing you're probably an expert
of some sort so you need to replace the
product expertise so first you got to
get a person then you get the process
the process around this is called the
beta process every single private equity
firm that we talked to loved this
process so you can write it down i
actually learned this from management
consulting the way that it works is that
if we need to solve a problem so there's
always a problem to be solved right
all these ask your customers there's
plenty of problems right so ask them
these are
uh problems your clients have problems
is that what you're talking about yeah
yes and then they can upvote the ones
that are the most salient to them you
take the ones that are the most that are
that are plaguing the most people and
then you say hey who here is doing
really well with this and then you get
you draw uh draw a line and ideally it's
depending on the client size for us we
look at the top one percent so we've got
a thousand locations top one percent is
ten people so i want a group of 10 to 20
that are in the top echelon so cut the
percentage wherever you want to get 10
to 20. and then we do a round table and
so the benefit to them is that they get
to kind of get a bonus mastermind with
you for free in exchange for sharing all
their secrets yep what we do then and
this is the qualitative process is that
you write down everything that each of
them says
step two is that you reorganize the
notes and find the common commonalities
and the point here is not to do all of
the things they do but to do the things
that all of them do
and so a lot like the list that i had
for reducing churn was like 180 items
between all the guys but the one thing
that the five things that all of them
did is the only five that i took to make
the solution and so once you have that
you consolidate the solution and then
you take the guys who are the bottom 10
and some middle guys and you say hey i
have now productized the solution and
you deliver it the same way you would to
your customers which is through a portal
involved well you don't do anything
actually because if you did then it
would [ __ ] up the results you say i need
you to go through this and we're going
to report back in 30 days right you can
sit you know have a cadence with them
you know once or twice a week whatever
you then measure the results here's
what's cool about this
one is if it works
you just have something that delivers
tons of value and you didn't have to
generate it it process generated it
which means it's not you you're not the
guru you're not the face a process
drives the innovation yep
the second thing is if it doesn't work
you still report it because every
entrepreneur would love to know failed
tests yeah i would love to know if this
headline worked at this one even if it
didn't i want to know because then i
don't want to try it and so it still
provides value even if it doesn't work
because you proved it didn't work so i
just want to share that with you because
if some of you guys do experiments and
they didn't work share them it's
valuable
so that's on the product side right
on
the the marketing side
we slowly introduced other people in the
ads until eventually it was just them in
the ads right and then additionally we
obviously started the outbound team so
that we had multiple channels so there
was like name was one issue which we
solved by getting me out of the inbound
and then
channel dependence was the other issue
which we solved through outbound right
and so those were the you know those are
the two solutions uh on that now i want
to share something that i think is more
important than everything that i've said
so maybe you can unshare the the thing
for a moment
um
when when when
i'm sharing the things that are working
for the outbound team you can't do it
like you can't do it like if you get to
a certain point if you're at 10 million
or 15 million like you can't do it you
need other people and you you can't hire
people with the intention of training
them to do the thing it's not hey we
need to build an outbound team together
it's
i know that you built two outbound teams
for similar type products as me
i need you to do the same thing here
here's some really favorable upside
potential for you
uh and i need you to build it from here
and i'll give you all the leeway in the
world i'm incredibly patient as some as
long as i see progress yeah
so i have very low patience if i see no
progress if i see progress you can go as
long as you want as long as we're making
progress because i know we will
eventually get there and so i think that
if you use that as a frame of mind that
we're not looking for people who know
how to run but we're looking for people
who have already run an olympic gold and
want to run another one and i'm telling
you if you find the players
you will be able to build something
significantly bigger and this was a
breakthrough that took me way too long
to learn and it sounds stupid because
it's so trite and overstated but like
you need to find champions and you got
to pay him well and it will be worth it
and there's a book i don't know if layla
put it in there but there's a book
called uh the motive
which is a one-sit read it's 130 pages
with big text
and
it it fundamentally changed me as an
entrepreneur
and i really think
everyone should read it because you can
read it in an hour and a half and it
will change the way you see operating a
business
because at the end of the day it's just
an assembly of people if you want it to
be a business if it's you with a
thousand helpers it's not a business
it's just a really high paying job right
and so you got to get people who can do
it i know it sounds stupid and it's
obvious but like
that's the belief is that and i was
stuck at mid 30 million for three years
and i had mark ford who wrote ready fire
aim write his book
and he said that the thing that you get
stuck at thirty and i like skip to the
chapter where he had 30 million as a
breakdown and he said if you're stuck
here it's because you're the only one
that's you're the juju you're the steam
you're the fuel behind the growth of
this thing but at a certain point
there's only so much that one person can
push it you get the fourth level of
infrastructure in the business and they
don't know who you are they don't know
your vision they don't know how you do
things because they're so far they're so
far three levels you're okay
fourth it's an organization it's it's
beyond tribe right
um and so i was going somewhere with
that uh when i hit when we hit 30 and i
read the book
he was like you need to find
other people who can own their own p l's
and become entrepreneurs within your
company and what happens is it becomes a
shift from being a business to being a
conglomeration and so if you think about
amazon they're not amazon's not a
business right it's a business of
businesses it's a collection of
businesses that serve a purpose right
and so
i had to shift my thinking in terms of
how mine worked to we have a number of
business units that operate off of one
shared spoke of shared services we've
got it hr legal finance
all in the middle and then we've got
profit drivers that drive revenue across
the business units and the people who
drive those are responsible and
compensated based on the growth of their
business line or their product loan
and so then you get people who can start
making 300 grand 400 grand a year 500
grand a year if they crush it and they
should because otherwise they'll just
start their own version of your business
and so if you can give them that you can
attract the entrepreneurs um who want to
drive growth are really good operators
who just have a little bit less risk uh
you know tolerance yeah
is that big
so that's the so that that's that really
goes for any of them so like outbound if
you're going outbound or you're like man
no one can never market like me there's
somebody who's better than you yeah that
totally is it's it
it's bad for the ego and good for the
business
um
so dude can we talk for a minute about
um
about
i don't know what the word post exit
post
not even post exit but like post i've
hit my number
what yeah i'm bored what's my new role
uh
you know who am i what do i do that's
stuff just for a couple minutes yes
so i made a video on youtube about this
how passive income was overrated and uh
it was because we had completely
replaced ourselves in the business
and it was still making a lot of money
and uh and then we started acquiring
other pieces of businesses and whatnot
and those have continued to cash flow
and i was like what do we do like we
have nothing to do all day and so i
think what i messed up is that i
continue to pursue freedom right because
that's what all of us here at least i
did
is freedom was the goal right um
and i thought that it was freedom from
work
when
when in reality what i should have done
was freedom to do things that i wanted
um and for me i want to work
and it took me a year to give myself
permission to work again
because i always thought that if the
business relied on me it wasn't a
business and i was doing something wrong
and that was a story that i was telling
myself and i love working and i think
that if all of us achieve the levels
that we have right now it's because we
love working we love doing this and we
still have this dream of this exit in
our minds
but it's not it's i'm just it's it's a
it's a farce it's not true
and you wake up the next day and all you
do is you know and there's just an
another blunk of money there and you're
like well [ __ ] i mean you can only go
out to so many nice dinners and nice
restaurants and nice shows at some point
you're like i gotta do some [ __ ] and so
like i would say that you don't need to
go through it because i spent the last
months nine months doing nothing and
being bored out of my mind and wondering
why i even existed and then it just
eventually gave myself permission to
just do the things that i like doing and
it just happens to be that it makes
money great
and for me and again i got this from
sharon because it's been it was um so
good but like the things that light me
up are buying and building is it's
expansion
and so you know if we end up selling i
don't know they gave us the offer this
morning maybe maybe not um
but
i do know that whatever it is it's going
to be the decision will be aligned with
what i am building next yeah and if i
think that keeping this will help me
build that better faster stronger then i
will keep it if i don't think that and
i'll tell you this is when i was
contemplating the sale i i could not see
past the decision because it was an
unmade decision it was like black it was
like i lost my vision i couldn't see
past this unmade decision because it was
this variable this huge fork in the road
in my life i immediately
and i [ __ ] you not immediately knew what
we needed to do to grow the other
company to 30 million in ebitda and what
we're going to do for the new company
because i'm still building the next
company no matter what um and so i think
that the season that i just went through
and i feel like it took me two and a
half years
um was transitioning from ceo to owner
and it took a lot longer and it was a
lot more emotionally difficult
a lot more emotionally difficult than i
expected why
identity you know um
i mean layla had a conversation with our
team yesterday like it's so nice that
you guys are gone
i tell that story because it was really
good did you say that to them or they
said that to you no they said it to us
they're like i don't want to offend you
guys sorry thanks i thought it was like
i'm so great not having you guys in my
life sorry
no i just thought it was interesting
because if you know i think both alex
and i had always prided ourselves on you
know for me it was like i have to be the
example i have to be working my ass off
doing more than everybody else so that
they you know because they're all a
players and so i want them to see that
i'm doing the same yeah and i was
talking to one of our our guys who's
really stepped up and he's one of the
you know one of the highest ranked
people in the company and i check in
with him once a month rather than you
know the because he's not the ceo or ceo
and um
i said like how can i support you how
can me and alex help you know just want
to know at the end of the call he said
can i be really honest with you and i
was like yeah
he said it's really nice not having you
guys around
he's like yeah he's like you know
everyone feels so much more creative you
know they have to be way more
self-reliant and all of us have just
been able to step up so much more since
you guys have stepped out and so we're
just growing so much as a team we're so
much stronger
and i was like [ __ ] man like everything
that you do to get to like 90 of the
finish line the last 10 requires you do
the complete opposite yeah that's
fascinating
so everything about every entrepreneur
every level of entrepreneurship based on
my observation my personal experience
has been it's it's relinquishing control
or at least the perception of control
and so you know when you're when you're
at zero to a million you're giving up
can you force reset alex because here's
what i'd love to i'd love to do and i
think you're going there but i want to
yeah i want a mind melt so
we got this journey and we've got the
you know the zero to one
and then we've got the one to what's the
next jump is it
ten ten perfect
and i say it's like 30 to 50. it kind of
depends on the company
perfect and then we'll go up from there
a lot of the people on this on this line
right now are kind of in this space and
we've got some in in this space but can
you just do
like
top three
for this for this space right here
yeah to get past the million you have to
give up
um
everything with fulfillment
so customer success
customer fulfillment right yeah exactly
life fulfillment you have to keep up
the key part you're also giving up if
you're going one to ten you can't sell
anymore right you need someone you need
a team of people who are selling on your
behalf so it's you have to not only be
able to sell you have to teach people to
sell you have to know how to recruit
sales people you have to know how to
manage sales people you have to know how
to send sales people um and continue to
get them uh performing right and that's
a different skill right we know how to
sell how many people be like god i close
these people so easily and no one else
can sound like me it's like it feels
good but you're still way poorer than
somebody's got 20 sales guys closer for
so like just get over it like there are
people who are better than you at
closing because all they're going to do
all day is close you're still running a
business yeah so you got to stop selling
it's my opinion that 10 to 10 to 30ish
is you have to give up the marketing you
have you really have to
get beyond that and then at going 50
plus you know 30 to 50 plus it's like
you have to give up the leading which is
difficult
right and the
zero to one i'm just i'll throw it in
there for fun it's like you gotta stop
doing then you go to managing and then
you go to leading and then you go to
decision making
um and so you can say leading and
decision making decision making is above
leading
um that's kind of the ultimate i would
say exit is that people are making
decisions on your behalf oh my bad i got
this thrown around alex would you say
for 50 plus because this is what i was
thinking i was making a presentation
like this the other day and uh
i think for 50 plus you go from being
the leader of the company to you lead
like the one soul leader but you're
actually just the resource yeah you're a
guy you're just a guy you're an advisor
yeah you provide capital and you provide
connections network vendors that's what
like pe does that's what you know the
big guys do yeah this is great
so can i just say something to cap this
real quick is that so if you're stuck
right now
you have to think
what am i holding on to that i need to
give up
great question and when you're giving
away control i'm not saying okay well
i'm not going to be involved in sales
anymore it's like no you have to learn
how to put a good leader in there who
knows training systems who knows how to
recruit who knows how to hire and knows
how to send you know how to keep culture
and build a team that can that can work
together right those are a lot of
attributes and you know your skill is
how do you find that person because
because each one of the skills begs the
next skill you have to learn how to
close you got to learn how to teach
other people to close right then once
you have
got
captioning
not
right if you're available it then
there's there's this is you if you're
managing it's one right if you're
managing a manager is two right if
you're now leading business you're
leading people who have business units
right it's it's three right so and then
finally you know you're you're advising
and you're letting other leaders
lead directors who have managers and
customers and so right now
i think that this is our fifth level of
hierarchy uh within the organizations
and so they now function as assets
um that produce cash flow
yeah many innovators a million percent
this is so great